All right, guys. I want to touch on
trading with ICT kind of as your main
lens or framework versus kind of forming
something around profiling and auction
market theory and stuff like that. Um
so, by no means am I an expert ICT
trader or anything like that.
Uh but, you know, things like
fair value gaps, order blocks, uh
liquidity sweeps, things like that. Um
>> [clears throat]
>> The issue with them is that they don't
give you any read on what the actual
market condition is. You know,
oftentimes people will ask me or I'll
see in in chats and whatnot. Um that you
know,
is that an order block or did you mark a
fair value gap or things like that? And
at the end of the day, those things like
they're they're just inefficiencies or,
you know, nuanced things in the market,
right? So, like
a fair value gap is just like a, you
know, a buying imbalance or a selling
imbalance. So, it just means there's an
indifference between buyers and sellers
at that area. So, uh the market can come
back to rebalance that gap. It's not
enough to form a trade off of alone.
It's extremely hard to
identify what market condition actually
is or when that condition changes,
things like that, which you need to be
able to do to to understand kind of what
your bias and hypos are throughout that
day or session. Um it's very hard to
form a repeatable process based off of
uh just marking highs and lows,
looking at imbalances or fair value gaps
and just trading the gap. Um especially
with, you know, marking you know,
equilibriums and stuff like that. It's
not enough to get a read on what the
actual market condition is. So, by no
means, like I said, I I I I'm not an
expert ICT trader. I've never traded it.
Um
but anyways, you know, let's say that
for example, we looked at this Bitcoin
chart. We have uh I think it's now an
11-day composite. So, an 11-day profile.
Uh I have a fixed range profile over
that area. And then the gray box is uh
TPO. So, this is the time value area
high. They're both the same, but
nonetheless, we have an 11-day profile
here.
Um so, let's just kind of go back from
let's look at some examples. Again, if
there's some uh some hardcore ICT
traders watching this, maybe this will
bother you and I'll mess something up.
I've no idea.
Uh anyways,
when the market is rotational inside of
value,
it's pretty simple. So, value area high
is resistance and value area low is
support, unless of course you find
acceptance above a level, right? But,
that's totally different at that point.
That would be a condition change.
Uh, but ultimately you're looking for
shorts up here
or probably should be because again,
value area high resistance, value area
low support. And you're going to expect
this kind of condition to stay the same
until, you know, you see a break from
from balance or from value. So,
I'd say if you're trading ICT, for
example,
uh, again, let let's say you're looking
at you're marking swing structure again,
whether it's higher time frame, lower
time frame. Again, I'm just looking at a
a larger range we've had through, you
know, the two weeks now.
Um,
you know, let's say you were looking at
swing structure basically from this
point here.
Uh, so let's say that
let's let's look from here. So, again,
we'll look at swing structure, so this
would be your swing high, your swing
low, your swing high here,
uh, and then we break from value, right?
And then that's a break of structure.
So, based on, you know, market structure
here that we're looking at, that would
be uh,
bearish
based on swings.
So,
that doesn't give you a read on market
condition, though. So, the biggest issue
with that is that let's say that, you
know, you were now looking for shorts
into this fair value gap. So, this is
hard to see. Let me just move this out
of the way.
Right? Into this fair value gap,
right? We broke structure, so you had,
you know,
broke structure to the downside, you
want a retracement to to catch the trend
lower. Let's say you wanted to get short
around here,
right? To then trade lower.
There's a couple problems with that. So,
just based off of composite structure
alone, even disregarding VWAP, we have a
older two-week composite here. So, let's
just kind of go over couple things.
Don't need to get too in-depth.
I know my chart's a mess. Just disregard
all the levels right now.
This is a two-week profile, right?
Here's value area high, here's the POC,
here's value area low. So, it was a
rejection, right? It was a larger
rounded retest or rejection at this
level off of the two-week value area
high,
right?
Um so, following that rejection
go back to lower time frame again.
We started to form
we started to form kind of a local range
here. So, following that move
we formed this local range. So, again,
it's just rotational about that value
here for
I don't know
half or so, whatever that happened to
be.
Um and then price, you know, breaks from
that local balance. So, again, we talk
about
a break from this level. So, this is
value area low. So, again, support
inside of value, it's now resistance
outside of value, right? Unless you see
acceptance back inside which is what we
saw. So, we got a rejection of an older
composite or or
you know, yeah, I guess composite level.
Uh we formed a local
composite or local balance here, right?
So, again, this is resistance, this is
support, resistance, support. And then
we break from the local balance, so that
would be a bullish shift against local
balance, and we traded back inside of
the more significant 11-day profile.
Right? So, again, rejection off of older
composite local balance, break from
balance, bullish, acceptance back inside
of 11-day composite, bullish. So, again,
if you apply there's there's lots of
kind of
uh you know, there's kind of a framework
you can apply with looking at auction
market theory and stuff like that, but
um
when price trades back inside of value
or you see acceptance, so let's say, you
know, we see this, or we traded up with
high momentum here, we didn't get a
retest, but we traded back inside
um
based off of kind of the 80% rule
uh you expect it to trade to the other
side of value. So,
if you trade inside and value area low
is now support, right? Value area high
should be resistance, and that's going
to be your likely target or at least
towards the POC. So again, if we look
back at if you were to take short here
and we break structure to the downside,
you're looking for a short somewhere in
this fair value gap or imbalance. So
let's say maybe even pull the fib and
you have like a
equilibrium or or something, I don't
know.
There's your equilibrium, right? That
didn't work, right? You know, that's at
the edge of value, that didn't work. We
had a high pick up
uh high rate of volume or we traded
higher uh or even like your golden
pocket kind of fib level, the 618. That
didn't do anything either, it traded
straight through it. So that's an issue,
right? And then from there, value area
high is resistance overlapping with VWAP
levels, which I can
also kind of go over.
A couple quick examples of that.
Um so again, the condition just changed.
So the condition went from bearish
because we broke from balance, we put in
a bottom here at an older retest of the
I'm sorry, at a retest of the older
composite. We formed a local balance
here.
Right? We shifted bullish against that
and at the same time we traded back
inside of the 11-day composite, which
points to the move through value, right?
Again, same thing. So being that we
capped here
and we traded inside here, so this is
now support, this is now resistance cuz
we're inside of value.
You expect it to move back down to value
area low again, likely.
Right? If we remain rotational,
this will hold as support again.
Right? Or the the volume value area low
is a little bit higher, but nonetheless.
So again, same thing. If you were to
take a trade
in this fair value gap because we broke
structure again,
right? So let's say again, swing
structure, there's your low, there's
your high, there's your low. We broke
this high, so that's now the swing high.
You want a you know, long a retracement
to to go higher, right? Because we broke
structure to the upside.
The problem [clears throat] is that
we're rotational here, so
being that we capped here, you expect it
to go to at least here and we actually
traded much lower. But ultimately, you
expect it to go to value area low, which
it did. So you're buying in the middle
of value. This is not really a trade
location majority of the time. It's in
the middle of the auction. You want to
trade at the edges. So again,
if you were to pull a fib here or
something, I think equilibrium is a
common thing in in the ICT world. Right,
it actually produced a little bounce,
but ultimately it didn't trade higher at
all. It trended for about an hour and a
half, right? And then if, you know,
rolled over and died. So,
not going to provide a trade location
because the condition is rotational,
which means it points to here.
So, it gives you no read on what the
market condition is. Right, and this can
be applied over multiple different
profiles,
shorter duration, longer duration,
developing VWAPs, weekly through yearly,
uh prior period VWAPs weekly through
yearly, right?
Same thing here. If you were to take a
short here, right? You know, you see
equal highs here and a fair value gap,
right? This is how you probably see
this.
Uh
if you're trading kind of ICT, I think.
Um and even the POC wasn't here at this
point, by the way. So, the POC migrated
up here because of this price action
yesterday. It used to be lower, so that
wasn't even there. You couldn't even
kind of argue that if you were looking
at a profile perspective. But
ultimately, if you took a short here,
that wouldn't work because
we saw acceptance, so we expected it to
go to here. So again,
acceptance inside of value, we expect it
to run to the other side.
So, that's a couple flaws there.
>> [clears throat]
>> Uh even disregarding trying to get short
around here, right? Let's just break
this down again.
Uh if you were to try and get short on
that uh retracement because we broke
structure to the downside around 80.5K
in Bitcoin. That's going to be a problem
because if we look at VWAP, again, it's
the it's the same thing. It's a it's
another issue. So, if we look at
this is weekly value. So,
this box here, this static box, is
previous week value. So again, you can
apply that kind of AMT logic to this as
well as the developing week, which is
the one that's obviously developing and
moving.
So, the issue is that
this is previous week value. This is
developing week value.
So, if you tried to get short up here at
80.5k,
not only did we trade back inside of
that 11-day profile, that 11-day
composite, right, which points up,
we're now back inside of the developing
week,
right there, we traded back inside of
it, and we're now back inside of the
previous week. Right, so being this is
just an example where they're they both
basically overlap, they both point to
much higher, right? They both point to
value area high. So, the same 80% rule
applies to this. So, here's previous
week value high, and here's developing
week value area high, right? And that's
where we capped ultimately. We deviated
it, we traded back inside, we remained
rotational in
developing week and previous week,
right?
And again, it also points down to that
same level,
which was here. It also points to here,
80 basically 80k, right?
80k right there. So, if we're rotational
in this value as well, you'd see
basically the same thing.
Then ultimately we traded lower. So, if
you were to again, if you were to to try
and take a long around here, that's also
an issue because again, it's it's in the
middle of the auction. So, if you tried
to long
um
this bullish fair value gap right here,
right? That's not the edge of value, the
edge of value is down here. Conversely,
the edge of previous week and developing
week value and VWAP, given we're
rotational, is also lower. So, that
points lower as well. So, that's an
issue.
And now that we're outside of value,
right? This is now resistance, right?
This was resistance.
Sorry, this was resistance outside of
value, we now traded inside, it's now
support,
and we capped upside, so now we expect
it to be rotational. This is resistance.
Obviously, we flushed lower, right? It
was supposed to be support, we traded
through it. Now, the condition has
changed, right? So, now
I know the condition is is is now
bearish against these levels, this
should act as resistance,
right?
So, again,
that's why I recommend that, you know,
trading
basing your your whole concept or your
your whole strategy or your your whole
framework off of
inefficiencies in the market. It's just
simply not enough to have a repeatable
process over time. Right? You can't get
a read on what the market condition is
when you can use kind of a
AMT framework to look at,
you know, composite structure, you know,
larger composite, smaller composites,
shorter-term VWAPs, longer-term VWAPs,
both developing and prior, right? So, we
have
developing week, prior week, we have
yearly, we have 2025 value, 2024 value,
we have developing quarter, we have
previous quarter, we have developing
month, right? So, again, we're
rotational in developing month. That's
where we put in that low, and then we
traded higher. And then that was that
impulsive move up is seen right here.
So, we're rotational in monthly value.
So, right now, we're sort of still
chopping on that level. So, if we break
down from monthly value and we truly
trade lower, that means we're going
down. Same with quarterly value, right?
This points to lower, as well.
So,
just a really good example of going over
all of that stuff. Cheers, guys.